Pictures are one of the most incredible inventions.
Snapshots in time of people, places, and events—frozen
forever, along with all of those special memories
and feelings attached.
They can convey emotion, illustrate ideas,
and even inspire the human spirit.
But we mostly use them to take pictures of
our food.
Let’s take a look at some interesting facts
you may not know about one of the most popular
photography and social networking apps out
there: Instagram.
The computer code powering the social media
powerhouse known as Instagram was written
over a period of eight weeks by cofounder
Kevin Systrom, though he says that over a
year of work went into the final product.
He taught himself the art of computer programming
in the late hours after his day job, developing
a few basic ideas that helped him to hone
his programming skills whilst laying down
the groundwork for the app we know and love.
The name "Instagram" is a mash up of "instant"
and "telegram".
It was inspired by the way snapshots are taken
with the app and sent "over the wire" to others.
Sure, it’s not technically accurate, but
it’s a lot catchier than “Insta-teleport
your pictures through the air”.
The popular trend of making nostalgic posts
to social media known as "Throwback Thursday"
first began on Instagram.
So remember to thank Instagram the next time
your friends share that old embarrassing photo
of you.
The app was initially released on October
6th, 2010.
It figuratively exploded overnight, gathering
over one million registered users by the end
of the year.
By December of 2011, Apple named Instagram
their App of the Year, and the world of hastily
posted meal photography with a filter slapped
on top hasn’t been the same since.
Former wrestler and Hollywood superstar Dwayne
“The Rock” Johnson organized a crowd of
fans at a movie premier in London in order
to break the world record for most selfies
taken in three minutes, as recognized by the
Guinness Book of World records.
In November of 2010, the Instagram team made
the decision to move into an empty office
in San Francisco’s South Park.
But it wasn’t just any old office, it was
the former first office of another social
media powerhouse known as Twitter.
Hot off their first month of resounding success,
the fledgling team was eager to make a statement
to the rest of Silicon Valley: they were ready
to join the big leagues.
Popular musician Ellie Goulding created an
entire music video for her song "Anything
Could Happen" using nothing but fan submitted
Instagram photos.
The video features twelve hundred photos stitched
together with some snazzy editing for the
entire three minute and fifty-one second runtime,
immortalising her lucky fans for as long as
YouTube persists.
Equal parts creepy and cool, Instagram allows
you to tag your current geographical location
when you snap a selfie.
Using their Photo Map feature, you can see
every place you and you friends have taken
pictures, for better or worse.
Just remember not to tag your location when
you’ve just called in sick to work but you’re
actually on an impromptu camping trip with
your mates.
In 2012, Facebook purchased Instagram for
an estimated one billion US dollars in cold
hard cash and company stocks.
Instagram’s Twitter account has made 6,497
posts for its 39.6 million followers.
It only follows three users in turn: Instagram
@music and the two cofounders of the company.
However, even with that many followers it
lands only 12th on the list of the most followed
Twitter accounts, behind the likes of Barack
Obama, Youtube, and Twitter itself.
One of Instagram’s early prototypes was
titled “Burbn” named after one of cofounder
Kevin Systrom’s favorite drinks.
The most popular filter on Instagram is actually
no filter at all!
Sometimes a good picture just speaks for itself.
Other times, you really should have dressed
it up at least a little.
The line between those two worlds is perilously
thin, my friends.
As of January 2015, Instagram sees traffic
from over three hundred million monthly active
users.
That’s a whole lot of people chronicling
the minutiae of their lives with the humble
photography app, falling just shy of the total
population of the United States.
According to a study performed by AT&T, a
staggering 70% of drivers admit to using their
phones whilst driving.
From that group of naughty drivers, 14% admit
to have been using Instagram.
Who knows, in future public awareness advertisements
might be telling you not the add filters to
selfies and drive.
The first Instagram photo was uploaded on
July 16th, 2010, whilst the app was still
in development.
Two short years after the first test picture
was uploaded, over one billion user-shared-photos
had joined it in the cloud.
The most followed account on Instagram is,
unsurprisingly, Instagram itself.
Next in line is the ever-popular singer and
actress Beyoncé, with almost forty million
followers as of July 2015.
Following close behind is the no less influential
but perhaps far more controversial Kim Kardashian,
with around thirty nine million followers.
In a study which included many Instagram sourced
photos, it was determined that filtered photographs
are 21% more likely to be viewed and 45% more
likely to be commented on by viewers.
The spike in engagement was most noteworthy
with filters that boosted the picture’s
warmth, exposure, and contrast.
Back in 2012, when Instagram was managed by
just fifteen employees and still surging with
bewildering popularity, certain unsavory types
began to use it as a platform for sharing
x-rated images.
Since then, the development team has worked
hard to tone down the titillating content
in favor of more family friendly fare.
But have they succeeded?
In January of 2015, an Instagram user had
their account banned for showing a little
too much besides their bikini.
To put it bluntly her pubic hair was on show.
Instagram reversed their decision in short
order, after reviewing the case and determining
that there was no actual nudity on display,
but a staunch debate continues to rage on
to this day between Instagram and the feminist
community, over what should be considered
censorable material.